look at this latest it's all about the
wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats i have a thing
about strange you guys have the greatest
chemistry i wanted to ask you about the
first scene in the film where you both
are alone zoe i think you said it was
the first scene that you guys shot
together
and it was just so
hot for lack of a better word i couldn't
figure out another word to say
what conversations were the both of you
having on set while you were shooting
that to build that chemistry because
it's so visceral
well the scene you mean the scene in my
apartment
i think it was in the mansion actually
okay yeah yeah that's um that was the
first scene that we shot um like a
little bit of uh
fighting in your hotness
we get it we get it we get it we see you
no i think it was a it was a great place
to start because it was so physical and
we were so focused on the choreography
and stuff and um so it was yeah it was
intense and you know it's always a
wonderful challenge to have to express
things without words
yeah so he's also deceptively strong for
being such a tiny person as well i'm
trying to kind of
trying to do this like sultry scene
where it's like you're being you're
succumbing it's his power it's very very
difficult no it's like get on me he was
like there's an accident a little bit
please i'm small but i'm scrappy
i love it were there different
conversations going on on set that the
two of you were having during that sort
of dance
no honestly the it was like this
this is crazy right
just consistently yes it's batman that's
nice and also kind of taking off the cow
having to be like it's always spending a
lot of time so can you please stop
sweating yeah a lot of sweat on my face
from rob's face
rob i also noticed watching it that this
is just the most brooding batman that i
think we've seen i i felt that he you
played him so well he was so intense and
intimidating i was wondering what
direction did matt give you on set and
did you have a conversation with him
regarding that that just made it click
as far as like intensity goes
i think it was just from the script the
uh
traditionally that bruce wayne's
supposed to be a kind of society playboy
and
there's a kind of playfulness to him and
uh as soon as you took that out just the
the actions of becoming batman it's a
very disturbed thing to do
and uh i think the script and matt's
direction really allowed me to kind of
play him as damaged as possible and he
also thinks he has he thinks he has the
weight of the world on his shoulders he
thinks it's his sole responsibility to
fix this city and uh even though no
one's asked him to he thinks he's just
decided
and uh you know it's pretty stressful
did he say anything to you on set that
you were like oh this is like how
intense i should be right now in this
moment
i really like the way matt directs in
the kind of
super minutiae and like there's a lot of
takes but once you get onto his rhythm
you can kind of feel i'm kind of quite
intuitive about what i'm doing i mean
i'm always just
it's a roll of the dice like every take
i don't really have that much control
over it but then matt would be
when you felt it matt always felt it and
so it's kind of it was a
it was a kind of uh
unspoken language that we develop quite
quickly zoe because i know a lot of
previous cat women were so supportive
when you got the role and i was
wondering did any of them reach out to
you and if so like what did they say
uh not personally but there were some
wonderful and sweet messages you know on
through interviews and and online
of you know just welcoming me and
embracing me and uh you know i saw
michelle in person soon after i got cast
and she just smiled and said you're
gonna be great i was like
good luck thank you seriously she was
like
no no they've all been so so encouraging
what's black
and blue
[Music]
this is the most stunning batman film
i've ever seen there were so many iconic
images batman the upside down walking
shot the flare the gunfight the strobe
lights it was just i literally wrote
down
how do you do you know when you're
creating an iconic image and when does
it come to you in the creative process
you know
i start
at the script stage trying to write in
shots because i'm trying to figure out
how to make the movie i mean when i'm
sort of um
writing i consider the process like to
be
in the dark room sort of on hands and
knees looking for things that you grab
on to that suddenly resonate and you
start putting them together until the
story forms and so i start by trying to
write the shots then
when we're making the movie as we're
prepping i kind of lay out the shots we
did this movie i did it in in um in vr
so i was able to go into the sets before
we ever shot and made
all of these shots that you're seeing
the shots you're talking about in vr so
that we could look as so much of the
stuff when you're doing a batmobile
chase that's a very highly technical
crazy act and so to go in there so like
the shot that upside down shot was a
shot that i found in vr and i was like
oh that would be really cool and all of
the shots are almost always guided by
this idea of subjectivity of putting you
into a character's point of view so that
you know that upside down shot is upside
down because penguin's looking at this
kind of crazy mythic figure that to me
when i was writing i always imagined
that being almost like apocalypse now
where kurtz is kind of walking and he's
carrying like chef's head and he sort of
puts it into um martin sheen's lap and
when he does that you're kind of like oh
my god he's just this very visceral
sort of um iconic and unsettling mythic
figure and that's really what i really
wanted was batman to seem mythic and so
yeah i mean when you're shooting i was
going oh that's a cool shot i really i
hope people connect to it what's really
fun is when these trailers are coming
out when people are seeing the movie and
they connect to them the way that you
did that's really satisfying because we
were trying to craft these things but
you never know are people going to
connect to it the way we're intending
and it seems like you did so that's very
cool matt so many people are going to
connect to this i am so proud of you at
vr i have a million follow-up questions
i can't yeah that's that was a really
cool i mean that process it was really
unique on this one james chinlund
designed the sets in vr and he could
walk me through them before they were
ever built and we could go and act out
the scenes and we could say oh you know
what actually i think you need to move
the stairway because there needs to be
an entrance here because he's going to
do this and he could do all those things
and then i realized wait a minute why
can't i take so greg and i you know greg
had researched and done all these
incredible lenses that he wanted us to
use and we took those lenses and we put
them into vr so i could throw on the
lenses we had this lens that we called
the crazy 88 because it was a really
weird lens that had these beautiful
qualities i could throw on the 88 and
say what would that look like here and
find shots and so it was a really it was
a brave new world and that technology is
going to be available for like this idea
that you could make and plan your movie
in vr is totally something that you
could do even on a small budget now
because you could you could design the
set in a very simple way and then go in
and set the lenses and sort of move
figures around and that's what we did so
i found it really exciting i feel like
that's the brave new world of movie
planning is to be able to be in your
spaces in some way and because for me
i'm very tactile i can't normally when
i'm looking for a shot i need to be in a
location and stand there and kind of go
like wait take a step to your left here
oh that's good and you you come up with
some of them on the page but being on
the set is important so to be able to be
in vr before the sets are ever built
that's incredible
[Music]
paul i was thinking about how as batman
fans when we think of laughing we think
of the jokers laugh but i was curious as
to how you crafted the riddler's laugh
and his mannerisms
yeah so the expectation on something
like that is is such a curse that you
just have to kind of you know push out
the door and it sometimes takes a while
right because
or you just gotta face it head on
matt's version
of
the riddler
at first i was afraid there wouldn't be
any laughs the guy is so damaged and his
anger is coming from a place of such
pain
but then i found okay that's his past
and this mask actually allows him to
access his power
so any any of those choices really came
from who he
was and who he couldn't be to who
he he now can be uh and just letting
that come out uh through the mask
wow did you have to practice like
laughing in different ways or
i probably i probably did some
embarrassing things and you know did
what i have to to to do um uh but that's
all like super in private because it's
it's such a strange job and process and
then you try to cultivate a reality
frankly
where
hopefully what's scary about it
ultimately is how real it is that that's
that's what i'm aspiring to well you
landed there jeffrey i was so moved by
your performance of jim gordon because i
felt like so viscerally you could feel
how much he believes in batman i like
truly felt it i was curious did you and
rob come up with an origin story
before filming because i was wondering
why does he trust batman so much um
we did talk uh among ourselves matt and
rob and i about how they've come
together
and
it's year two as you know
um there's so much decay within gotham
that i think it's really born out of a
almost a desperation the thing that i
kept coming back to with gordon was the
sense of being overwhelmed the sense of
being overwhelmed by you know the
individual circumstances of these
this series of crimes but also
overwhelmed by the the disintegration of
this of this society around him and so
his relationship with
with
uh with the batman is almost like you
know
on an island reaching out for you know a
life-saving life-saving vessel to rescue
him and i think for the batman there's a
similar isolation but
there's something that he sees in gordon
that he doesn't see
that he doesn't see elsewhere certainly
not within the
gotham police department and so it's a
you know it's a yeah it's a marriage
born of necessity um
you know and i think gordon is at the
point where
he's just willing to take take the leap
and i think the more that batman
satisfies
that leap of faith
that gordon places in him the closer he
becomes to him because he becomes a kind
of caretaker for batman certainly within
uh you know the community of those in
the police department who see him as an
enemy
i got you
you killed this and last time i spoke to
you i asked you about penguin suit but
now i wanted to ask you about penguin's
voice now having seen the film because
so much of his personality is
in his voice and it's so different than
your own voice i was wondering what were
you listening to to like help you find
this guy
oh i can't remember the gentleman's name
but there was i i have a wonderful
dialect coach that i've worked with now
for eight or ten years i've been really
lucky enough to work with a few
fantastic dialer coaches but jessica
drake is uh the woman that i've done the
last 10 jobs with her so
um and she and i sat in a room and
listened to audios listen to tapes
thought about characters and films we've
seen that might have kind of an
energetic not just a dialectic quality
but an energetic quality a tonality that
we thought oz might have so
that can be it can be kind of it was fun
it's a journey of exploration you know
and we just explored and explored and
there was one older gentleman who was
the caretaker of a building in new york
he's the building manager and he's since
deceased and when this audio was made i
think it was the 80s and i think he was
probably in his late 70s when it was
made and he was the one john that said
gefilte fish and uh and we used him kind
of as as a reference and you're not
copying him but there was a certain
quality to him there was a certain kind
of humor that he had a certain kind of
sarcasm that he had it's all those
little things but i give credit to
jessica drake my dialect coach for
whatever that was that you enjoyed wow
and shout out to to that man that's
amazing and you nailed that nuance i
loved it so much fun to watch you too
john i mean for me carmine is such a
legacy character and this is the most
we've seen of him and the most mobbed up
batman movie i think we've ever seen so
i was wondering what was your
inspiration in terms of coloring him
like what comics did you read or did you
go back to mob movies no i went to the
frank miller uh matt used that as a
reference year one the last halloween
and that was obviously influenced by the
godfather and the book and the godfather
book was influenced by a lot of real
life figures
and so i looked at some of them you know
and how they looked and the glasses that
they wore they were always kind of
hiding their eyes
but you know there were people who were
there a long time and then actually
became legit and are the ones who didn't
but who had their hands in everything
and lived a really subterranean
existence not flashy at all uh
and
they they were there a long long time
their sort of predatory behavior you
know coming in and finding people's
vulnerabilities and taking advantage
saying they're going to help them and
then you know they own you uh so i i
thought of sort of
him almost as a politician in some ways
you know or a strong man in some ways uh
and uh
you know there is
the world of everything he's done but he
it's try you know he
he presents himself as a very uh
quiet and simple man you know but those
are the people you have to be really
careful of sometimes you know yeah
yeah he is he's a subterranean creature
yes he's certainly a parasitic
you know in in in
certain ways but you know
he sees the vulnerability like in bruce
for example it's two sides of the coin
you know and matt seems seem to be
interested in that and
it was a lot of fun to uh
to kind of play around with
you can tell that both of you guys are
having fun i can't wait for the world to
see both of you in this film colin what
are you excited to further explore with
penguin in your spin-off series because
i know people are so stoked for that
uh
just his
his ambition
and his vulnerability
his humor i mean it was just the tip of
the iceberg in this film for me but
there were there were kind of
there were little moments in the script
that matt wrote in relation to oz little
bits of humor and awkwardness as well
and and his origin you know why he is
the man he is and all that stuff we just
if we get six or eight hours to do it i
just think the character
could be endlessly fun and fascinating
and brutal and i hear that we're going
to be allowed kind of do an orated
version perhaps which would be nice to
explore that
the violence that that could permit
perhaps and the darkness that that could
allow us to explore all those things